so tell me how you come up with this
like what is the business model
is it mainly are you guys sitting in a
creative room and everybody pitches is
it a lot of pitching pitching pitching
how do you guys come up with these
titles a lot of pitching yeah i mean so
we primarily we're riding on the back of
whatever's in the news cycle right so we
want to be timely with it we want to be
writing about whatever people are
currently thinking and talking about so
uh we wake up in the morning and look at
the headlines read the headlines and
when i say we i mean my team it's not
it's not me personally for the most part
doing this i do pitch ideas but but we
have a whole team of writers who are uh
you know they're in the slack channels
pitching ideas it's all in the headline
right we start with a headline we don't
create the image we don't write the
article we write headlines and pitch
them over and over and over again until
we get one that's right or we iterate on
it and you know we've got like a seed
thought that's good but the headline is
not worded properly
we'll you know keep rewriting it tossing
it back and forth until we get nail it
and then once we got the joke in the
headline then we hand it off get the
photoshop done get the article written
up and all of that so we pitch for every
article we publish there's probably 100
150 headlines pitched um that we're
turned down that were turned down that
didn't go live how many go how many
every day how many did you guys post
every day
we probably publish between five and ten
new articles a day depending on the day
and then we also repost some evergreen
stuff from so only for five to ten a day
so yeah our model is
to come up with the best five or ten a
day yeah yeah got it yeah you know
people can only handle so much satire in
their news feed and they're only going
to share so much satire um so i don't
think it makes sense to have a model
where like fox news we're publishing an
article every three minutes you know
throughout the course of the day
there's just no way to inundate people
with it like that it's not the right
kind of content so we're going for for
quality over quantity so how much is
obviously i would have to say the king
of satire for satire business is trump
he's got to be at the top i don't right
i would put him at the top
for who to satirize a target yes no okay
so this might be this it's debatable but
trump on the one hand is low-hanging
fruit right right
if you say he's not though
he will that uh he on the one hand he's
low-hanging fruit because he's like an
outrageous personality biden kind of the
same way he's he's you know he mumbles
this gibberish sometimes he's hard to
understand he says crazy things he
sniffs people's hair he does weird stuff
it's easy to make fun of um
but
when you're exaggerating the truth to
make your point when the truth is trump
is an exaggeration himself so you got
regular reality then you got trump who's
like a crazy guy and then you got to try
to exaggerate him you're exaggerating an
exaggeration i find it more challenging
to parody that which is already a parody
of itself so trump seems like a
character out of a movie already
so i think it's challenging to parody
things in fact i've i quote gk
chesterton all the time he said back in
1911 the world has become too absurd to
be satirized he said that over 100 years
ago today we got crazy stuff happening
really crazy stuff happening that
actually makes the project of satire
more difficult because it's hard to
exaggerate something that's already so
exaggerated and and uh you didn't answer
my question so who would be at the top
who would be the goats to satirize um is
it is it a bush is it a uh
like today there's people like i think
fauci is an easy one you know because
fauci's been kind of on every side of
these issues he's said things that
contradict himself sure over and over
again so we've made jokes about how
fauci debates you know hit the five
previous versions of himself
is that hard to do when you're the
sexiest man alive like it's kind of
tough to do that right see that's funny
the fact he's like been on the front of
magazines but he's like this elderly
doctor it's just the whole thing is just
funny it's bizarre unexpected um so i
think he's he's a good one i think that
the more outrageous the personality like
trump the more difficult it is but also
when you just nail it when you get it
just right i wrote a a piece a a
headline about how trump went twitter
went down for a few hours right
and so i pitched a headline to the team
about how uh okay he can't tweet because
twitter's down this is before he got
suspended like what would trump do what
would trump do okay let's do a story
about how he because twitter's down he
went out on the balcony of the white
house and was just shouting his thoughts
to whoever was listening you know so he
did a piece about like during twitter
outage trump is out on white house
balcony just shouting his thoughts to
like whoever's in earshot just to
whoever you know just because he has no
no other outlet for it and it was funny
it got shared a ton of times because it
was kind of like kind of believable but
also pretty silly um so for for those
reasons trump is fun but it's it's
really challenging to find just the
right angle on him so if you like this
sort of shortcut from an interview i did
click over here to watch the entire
interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]